we've seen what more permissive
approaches to Crime did in the 1960s
when social upheaval plus the spread of
recreational drug use gave way to urban
riots and Rising crime the violent crime
rate in the 60s increased 126 percent
between 1960 and 1970. that's according
to the pretty liberal Brennan Center for
justice
but the fact is
tough on crime policies worked when we
had them and they were attacked however
as racist and unjust and then they were
ultimately ditched in cities like New
York
crime went up
now leftists may have been pleasing in
their conduct thrilled they were
thrilling The Faculty at Yale and
Columbia law school when they pushed
cities to pursue so-called bail reform
or ending stop and frisk but
it's nothing but doing the opposite of
what most people want they're putting
criminals back onto the streets
in the anti-law and Order crowd is so
fanatical they're moving full steam
ahead in fact today Illinois became the
first state in the nation to eliminate
cash bail completely
and this is Chicago is still in the
grips of violent crime but radical
politicians like the Speaker of the
House there Emanuel Chris Welch
celebrate
we've heard a lot of falsehoods about
this historic law we heard a whole lot
of racist dog whistles too
and we're still hearing them
but let's be clear
the pre-trial Fairness Act makes
Illinois a national leader in Criminal
Justice Reform and we are making our
communities safer
I'm gonna go off script for a moment who
thinks that's going to make Illinois
safer we'll check back in a year
meanwhile this is what is considered
good news in Chicago over the weekend 24
people were shot but no reported
homicides that was only the second
weekend that happened all year
but the fact is crime is going to
continue to rise and innocent people
will continue to be victims of it until
voters in urban America say enough is
enough and until those Suburban voters
also decide
that there's only one party out there
that's putting racial politics ahead of
safety and that's the Democrat Party
it's time to take a chance elsewhere
so I predict next year more women and
more minorities will choose safety and
Sanity over dangerous virtue signaling
gosh let's hope so and that's the angle